kamala harris looking for the lifeboats
on biden's sinking ship that's an
analogy apparently not wanting to put
her future political ambitions in
jeopardy
the vp has been quietly shunning joint
public events with the big guy she used
to be by his side all the time but now
events between the two are on the
decline they reportedly appeared
together 18 times in february but just
once in september and once in october
dana apparently she's unhappy because
she didn't get any fun jobs she's
getting like crappy jobs she wants to
have fun yeah um i don't know if she
understood what the vice presidential
role was but with any story of a breakup
or a will they or will they not break up
you have to ask who's breaking up with
who
it is i think her team or somebody is
putting out the story like this
to say that she's like whoa i don't know
i don't want to be a part of him but
don't you think it could be the exact
opposite right that the west wing is
saying uh we don't want it like hey why
don't you go and do this in fact
yesterday she put out the national
gender strategy yes gender what strategy
national gender strategy she's not going
to glasgow with the rest of the entire
federal government but they announced
she will be going to france oh well
that's good that's good she'll be
determined if james taylor is going with
her no there you go
so uh jessie um it uh she failed at the
border so why does she get a second bite
of the apple why should she because they
have a gender strategy and that strategy
is much more important than the border
strand they gave it to a woman how
sexist is that very sexist i'll say it
now and i've said it before she's the
worst female vice president in american
history yeah i i back you on that i know
and everybody does but dana is right
it's like they're both avoiding each
other because they don't want both of
their bad poll numbers to rub off on
each other it's pretty funny so
her numbers are historically bad like
she's she's
less popular than pence
than gore
than dick cheney than joe biden was when
he was with barack obama and now she's
complaining like she's not getting great
roles like she got the border she went
over to asia to look at the supply chain
crisis firsthand and the only thing she
came back was was oh do your christmas
shopping early some toys from china
right so and now she's traveling all
over the country and she's pushing by i
have a job agenda and this just be like
dana permission to make a sports
analysis of course this would be like a
wide receiver that just dropped three
passes and then complains to the press
after the game that he's not getting the
ball enough oh dale beckham she's
blowing it every time she gets the ball
she blows it quickly she's being held
hostage so i really and seriously take
this opportunity to bring up a hostage
crisis that kamala harris could figure
in in a very prominent way there are 16
american missionaries seriously being
held in haiti by thugs there threatening
their life demanding a million dollars
for each of them 16 americans are being
held hostage nobody is talking about it
from the christian aid ministries
they're going to hurt these people if
the ransom's not paid or if our people
don't go in there and free americans
americans are being held hostage people
are talking about afghanistan and here
and there this is hundreds of miles just
a couple hundred miles from the united
states
16 americans including five children one
of them an eight-month-old baby held
hostage kamala harris could get involved
in that issue
she could be the bag lady
bring the big bag of money yeah i don't
know digging does she really want to do
anything other than like that space jam
video she kind of had that look of like
wait where's jennifer lawrence and will
smith and de niro i thought i was going
to have different actors here with me
she had a great birthday
surprise uh she's gonna be in uh the
tidewater area in hamp norfolk with uh
pharrell williams campaigning for terry
mcauliffe on friday so she's getting to
hang out with a celebrity there she has
one thing going for it and she should
stand up next to joe biden as often as
possible you look at the two of them
she's the only per of the two you would
ride in a car with like she looks like
she's
capable of driving an automobile she's
got that one what are you saying
i'm saying that joe biden is inching
closer to pureed food and being fed by
people who work for how about me
we've seen you eat for all day you're
fine
next